so I have in the last lecture and just
now I've just given you the basic
definition neural differential equations
I also told you about this link between
ndes and newal network architectures and
then I told you about kind of a
state-ofthe-art Neal differential
equation model these coupled oscillatory
ons to to solve with high performance
these kind of machine learning
tasks so now I'm going to spend the rest
of the lecture talking about uh
diffusion
models uh so who's heard of diffusion
models before
pretty much everyone so who's actually
used the diffusion model who's trained
one okay two people okay great so um I'm
going to explain what a diffusion model
is and how it's actually linked or how
it can be interpreted as a as a noral
differential equation it's kind of
interesting
um
so these are this is examples of outputs
of some diffusion models and so who's
heard of Dary or stable diffusion yeah
okay so you probably played around with
it uh this is now publicly available you
can these models you basically type in a
prompt uh for example like uh a chair
that looks like a strawberry or
something I don't know uh and uh these
models will like imagine or just
generate a random image that looks like
that prompt or it's conditioned on that
prompt so they generative models they're
models that take an input and maybe some
random input as well and then generate
an image from that kind of conditional
distribution uh and they're super
impressive like just over the last five
years there's been so much improvement
in the the quality of these generated
images from these generative models and
kind of the the generative model that's
doing the best so far or is the most
popular at the moment are these
diffusion
models um so what is diffusion can
anyone tell me or give me a definition
of what they think diffusion is
yeah random movement of particles yeah
what exactly happens though when
particles are moving around
randomly yeah and diffuse yeah yeah so
so so you've got it so this is diffusion
is just the movement of it doesn't have
to be particles actually many processes
in in science can be thought of as
diffusion processes so let's just talk
about particles for now it's the
movement of particles from regions of
higher concentration to lower
concentration and and it's just this
movement is just driven by the random
motion of the particles the random
movement of the particles who's heard of
brownie in motion this isn't yeah so
this is an example of like random
particles randomly colliding with each
other and moving around kind of on a
random walk in some
space another example is uh is like gas
for example particles of gas so say say
they confined inside this box and then
uh we take out like one of the walls of
the box and make the Box bigger even
though these particles are just randomly
moving they they'll eventually start
diffusing into the into the wider
box and so what you end up with with a
diffusion process is you go from some
highly structured concentration to to
some uniform distribution that's
generally what happens in in
diffusion so uh people also use
diffusion to model other other things so
uh energy but also in uh Finance we can
use diffusion models to to model the the
evolution of stock prices it's basically
saying they they evolve
randomly uh from some initial
time so how is it used for images so for
these image models these generative
models that are using diffusion to
produce images it's just applying
diffusion to to an image so what we do
is we just start off with a with an
image on the left in and we just
interpret that each pixel as like a as a
as a particle if you like and we're just
going to let the pixel the pixel values
themselves just do a random walk like
start randomly moving around and diffuse
like
that mathematically that just means or
most of the case that means we'll just
add some galsi and noise to the P pixels
every every time every time step of of
the
evolution and so we just start adding
noise to to this image and what you find
is whatever image you take you'll end up
with some uh generally simple
distribution at the end in this case
case just a ging
distribution um
so this is really interesting this this
tells us that we can go from very easily
from an image to to some noise basically
at the end and it's just a diffusion
process that gets us
there everyone mve me so far yeah
okay so let's try and just Define it a
bit more mathematically what what this
process of diffusion is when we're
applying it to images so we can we need
to talk about
probability uh uh distributions because
diffusion is a random
process so we can just say that we we
start with some image here which is
drawn from some uh data distribution so
so P of X what does this mean this just
means uh it's just the probability of
that image occurring naturally like it's
the probability distribution of natural
images if we sample from this
distribution we just get a natural image
if you like that's that's the
distribution that we would like to learn
and then we apply diffusion all the way
down and we just we can assume that our
diffusion model is going to end us up at
some very simple well defined
distribution say a gan distribution over
those pixels this is our kind of Prior
we would call it a PRI prior
distribution and so we can model many
different diffusion processes uh with
stochastic differential equations who's
learned about sdes before stochastic
differential equations
okay so some some people not everyone
it's that's
okay so we can write this kind of uh uh
diffusion process is this this kind
of equation here where we say a small
change in in the image in the pixel
values
DX is just some deterministic process so
some you can imagine that maybe over
time they just have a deterministic
drift to them where their means just
change
slowly uh so this is just determined by
this drift function but then the
interesting thing is uh we also add uh
this small uh random noise to the image
uh here so we call this the diffusion
kind of change and what we just say is
that this kind of random variable that
we add to the images here this W is just
a just a wiener
process which can be a whole leure by
itself just describing mathematically
these kind of uh random random processes
but for now you can just think of it as
adding gaussian noise at each step and
and GF just tells you how much galum
noise we add the kind of magnitude of
that
noise any questions on this equation
does that make
sense no it does yeah okay good yeah
menus
process yeah yeah so this this weening
process describes like uh these uh
articles as they randomly like change
over time and so it's not a
deterministic movement you kind of have
to sum Le this process to when you're
when you're forward simulating SD you
have to kind of sample many paths to
create these distributions rather than
just a deterministic
part uh so yeah you have to Define kind
of the how W evolves mathematically is
like a probability distribution you just
say at time some later time the
distribution is like a gan
distribution so there's a super
remarkable result uh which was shown I
Believe by Anderson in the
1980s uh that we can go the opposite
direction and and so this is what we
want to do if we want to gener if we
want to um learn a diffusion model which
you know given some random input can
produce a sample from our from our data
distribution basically give us a natural
image what we want to be able to do is
to go from right to left we want to take
some prior distribution we want to
sample of gon distribution and turn that
into into an image here
and this is a kind of a really
remarkable result it says there is an a
corresponding stochastic differential
equation that if we solve this
differential equation reverse in time so
if we start at XT and and do time
stepping from T to
zero we will end up with a sample from
the from the uh initial distribution
from this data
distribution so I think this is a really
remarkable result it gives us a way to
to take some random image here and then
then just uh model it with a through the
stochastic differential equation to end
up with an image
here and what does this uh equation
depend on well it just depends on this
this the stuff that we already know so
this kind of uh this drift function here
and our diffusion function here um DW
here is just is another Weena process
it's just in Reverse uh so again can be
easily mathematically defined
um and the other thing that it depends
on which is not in the original forward
model is this PT of X so this is the
probability of X this kind of
distribution of the images as a function
of the time step so at time equals time
equals T the P of T is just this ging
distribution and at P zero it's the data
distribution and at T equals T it's
somewhere in
between so I'm not going to go into how
that's derived uh uh but it's worth
looking into and reading these papers to
kind of understand uh why there is such
a corresponding sde for the for the
reverse
model now you can actually go one step
further it can also be shown that
there's a corresponding ordinary
differential equation which if you do
the same thing if you solve this OD
backwards in time starting from some
sample of this prior distribution so
some random noise
image uh you will also end up with an x0
here that is drawn from again our data
distribution our P0
F so this is not a stochastic uh
equation anymore this is just a simple
standard
OD which is deterministic so we give it
a a random image here and it will give
you a deterministic kind of sample from
from this uh initial
distribution so I think this is another
really amazing result this is shown in
this song song paper how to derive this
OD and um it looks very very similar to
this reverse SD which so if we solve the
reverse SD we get lots of samples if we
solve the OD we just get single sample
but all of those samples are still
samples from this initial
distribution um and it looks very
similar so we again we have the the
drift term we have the diffusion term
and we have this the log of the of the
density through time
yeah yeah so when when you solve the SD
imagine taking an increment of X like
you have X XT here and we want to we
have to time we have to discretize the
to solve it as as we do normally so you
take to take one increment of X you you
apply this thing which is deterministic
but then when you apply the the Rena
process you have to sample like a random
gaussian noise that you'll add to the
image so you could do it once and just
create one sample and that would give
you one path but you could also each
time step you could also sample it many
many times and generate 10 samples for
for each time step
and then take those samples forward so
the next time step and like generate an
exponential amount of samples that way
whereas the OD is just defining One path
like a deterministic path but the cool
result is that the OD still gives at the
end of that path it will still give you
a sample drawn from this distribution so
it will still be a natural image it's
just a single natural image
yeah
mod yeah yeah yeah so so the B SCS model
can be is very similar to this so you
can use similar kind of Sol this as well
yeah uh
so so how do we generate an image so let
me just write it step by step um so it's
very simple there's just two steps uh we
generate a random image you know
sampling each pixel from a galum
distribution um or usually a gum so some
it depends on the SV that you define
some and the kind of final distribution
that it evolves to but often it's just
the
gum then you just solve this OD or the
reverse SD if you want uh backwards from
time T to time zero and it's just a a
simple we can use any OD solver that we
like that fits this this equation you
know so this could be Oiler this could
be anything you
like we have access to
yeah right so you you've just you just
asked asked my question or answered my
question so what's the what's the
problem here what do you think is the
problem
yeah we don't know what we don't know
what PT XIs this is like some super
complicated
function uh well we know it here we know
that this is a gaan but we don't know it
anywhere else this this is a really
complicated probably not never be able
to express analytically function
so what do you think we can do how can
we get around this
yeah
yeah yeah so we're GNA try and learn it
that's absolutely right so the the
process of training a diffusion model is
actually just the process of learning
this distribution this PT of
X but what we actually do is not it's
nearly that we we actually say we're
going to learn this whole term here so
this the gradient of the of the log of
the
probability and we just approximate that
whole term with with a newal network so
that's that's the goal is to train in or
network in some way which I'm going to
talk about
later so that it matches very closely
this this uh probability distribution or
or at least it's uh we call it the score
the score
function so what what are the actual
inputs and outputs of the network well
it's exactly the same as the as this
right hand side so this right hand side
depends on the image and a time so then
the network is going to take x and t and
produce uh some output so what
dimensionality output will that would
that be by the way if the if the network
takes in an image what does it output or
what's the diens dimensionality of the
output just from this mathematical
equation what what should it look
like yeah
yeah yeah yeah you got it so so this is
the gradient of a Scala function the
prob this is a this is probably an image
or a matrix this is now a probability
it's a single value this is a gradient
with respect to X so the output of s
will just be another kind of image you
or the shape of an image at
least
okay so how can we learn it anyone got
any ideas
yeah K diverence measures the similarity
between two probability
distributions
[Music]
so
um so you to be able to um match your
network to that you'd have to have some
data that you know is drawn from the the
ground truth distribution which we can
do here and here but I guess we probably
could do it here actually if we just do
lots of forward samping so
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I think that
could work yeah it's not how I've we've
typically defined it but that may be a
different way yeah anyone
else okay
so this is a well so one way it's not
the way that I'm going to describe next
but uh this is just
a this is just a nor nor OD
right once we replace the score function
with some noral network with some threee
parameters this is exactly an orod that
we've just been looking at so how do we
train these networks when we train or
ODS can anyone remind
me
yeah yeah yes so we we simulate it
forwards and then match the outputs with
respect to the inputs so we know that if
we simulate this the process we know
what the outputs of the of the backwards
so should be so we can match it to those
outputs that that's one way of doing
it the way that people actually do it is
uh to use this type of loss
function uh where we just say that um
very simply like even simpler we want
the the network just to match you know
this uh the score the score of the
probability distribution so I'm not
saying anything new just to say I'm just
trying to make sure that this is
true and we're just taking the L2 Norm
because this isn't this network outputs
an image that's the gradient of the
distribution um and we want to make sure
that this is true across all the inputs
of the score function right so that we
want to sample all the values of T and
all the possible values of
XT does that that makes sense as a
simple kind of loss
function okay so again you can I'm
taking multiple steps at the same time
here to give you the overview but there
is another paper you can read which says
that this uh expectation over T and XT
here can be Rewritten as this
expectation um where what we've done is
we've uh turned the kind of
unconditioned distribution as a function
of X here into a conditional
distribution of x given the initial
value of x so this is what does a no
what's the probability of a noisy image
given some initial noise distribution
here so yeah you'll have to look at this
paper to believe me that it's but this
is this is a equivalent
expectation so now we Define this the
probability of some X at time some time
given the kind of initial gaan value or
or initial prior image is the transition
probability uh of of the
system okay so let's just think of a
really simple SD let's forget about the
drift terms and the diffusion function
and just say that the diffusion of X is
just exactly a weener process and so I
told you before you can just think of a
weener process as adding gaussian noise
at each time step but it's kind of a
continuous version of that and and the
weener process actually tells us
analytically what this transition
probability is it says you know given
some starting image here the image at
time T is just uh you know some Gan uh
Gan different like a like it's the same
image but with some gting noise added to
it you know this is the distribution
and the kind of magnitude of that gaan
noise is just proportional to the time
the time so the standard deviation of
the g g Gan noise just depends on how
long the process has been evolving
for um can everyone kind of get the kind
of high level concept even though the
math might not look too
familiar
yeah so this is just a an expression
that we can take the the gradient of
with respect to X it's very simple you
can derive it is this that's very
trivial to
show and so then if we just plug this
transition probability into our kind of
transform loss
function we just say that uh the loss
now is just an expectation uh of the
output of the score Network and we want
to try and match it to one / T Times by
xus
XT so we're going to average this this
difference over all times all possible
uh initial uh random
images and then over all uh halfs of
that image
takes so all XT all XD
images uh and if you just look at this
in a bit more closely just think of
we're just what we're trying to match
the score Network to uh this is simply
just the difference between our random
noise and the image at time T so what
the score network is trying to do is
just predict the noise that's been added
to that image at time T that's kind of
just the interpretation of the of the
loss
okay hopefully that kind of gives you
the how we like the Lost function that
we often use to train the to train these
diffusion models any any questions on
this I recommend going through this in
your own time and think and uh uh trying
to see if it makes sense
mathematically
um okay
so here's the summary of the of the
fusion models like uh and then I'll give
you an example of of how we use them uh
in science
so how do we train a diffusion model so
first of all uh there's well there's
five steps first of all you need to get
lots and lots of examples of whatever
image distribution you want to model so
these could just be lot many examples of
natural
images then you have to assume some
underlying form of your stochastic
differential equation that is defining
that diffusion process as it evolves
through
time um and we need to to understand
what the transition probability is what
takes uh kind of the uh initial uh
initial image here to sometime t t here
what's the transition probability of
that
happening and then we Define our loss
function just as I said before and we
can differentiate through this because
we can analytically uh derive what this
score value
is uh so we train the network and then
uh when we want to generate an image
then we just sample uh or we we solve
this nor OD or if we want the the
reverse stochastic differential equation
given that learn score function uh
backwards in time uh to be able to
generate a new image so we start from
some random sample as the initial
condition of this OD and then we solve
it solve it through time with like an
oiless over or whatever other type of
discretized St you
like um so this review paper here this
by Yang gives a really nice uh goes a
bit more into the math behind diffusion
models if if you want to learn more
about that and give some a really good
overview of all the different extensions
of diffusion models and also their
applications today so I super recommend
this paper if you if you want to learn
more about
these uh okay any questions yeah
practice this D
[Music]
function yeah so if I go if I go to uh
if I go to this example where we have
like a stock for example so what this is
showing is the random uh random walk of
of a stock price if you sample it like
four times or five
times uh so this is like solving the the
S forwards in time for for a bunch of
variables for a bunch of yeah instances
so the drift function you can see here
if you look at the the Gan distribution
at the end it's just the center is
around zero so what that drift function
just does is Def find some deterministic
drift that that would otherwise end up
this this galum might like just drift
upwards linearly for example and that so
that would just be a linear function as
a function of
time yeah I'm not sure how to interpret
that properly I so uh have a look at
that review paper it's got it goes way
more into the different choices that
people make for these SD and uh the
types of diffusion models that they
produce it's really really interesting
okay
so we're now going to think about using
I showed you at the start the fusion
models are the State ofthe art for image
generation uh like generative models for
images but people are also using the
fusion models now to to solve scientific
problems and so what I have is an
example of uh the fusion model solving
computed tomography so everyone uh
understands this hopefully we covered
this when we were talking about hybrid
Methods at the start so again we we have
some sinogram that we observe from some
image so so we scan ourselves we want to
produce one of these uh x-ray images but
what the um device actually measures of
these sinograms it's the intensity at
the screen and so the goal is to do the
inverse problem take take this sinogram
data and try and reconstruct the image
or the the absorption as a function of
space uh uh here
okay so uh there was this paper that
came out very fairly recently from song
where they used the diffusion model to
generate these CT images so so you can
instead of learning the space of like
natural images now we want to learn to
sample like medical images so like image
you know images that would be output
from CT from CT
scans and you can imagine if I if I run
like a million CT scans I would have a
good training data set and I could train
diffusion model to generate new CT
images from that training data just
using the process or the training
algorithm that I just
described um but the problem is if I
just train that diffusion model as it is
uh when I sample it I'm just going to
get a random image I'm not there's at
the moment I don't have a way to like
incorporate the cogram into this
workflow so that it doesn't just produce
a random image it actually produces the
image that I want the the result of the
inverse
problem so can anyone think of a way
that we would incorporate our sinogram
into this workflow to to help the
diffusion model like come up with an
image that solves the solve the
problem what we're trying to do is
create a condition distribution here
we're trying to condition our our
diffusion model on some um observe data
to make to make an image that is like
the the
solution any ideas
well how could you use this diffusion
model in a traditional inverse algorithm
as well like how could you use
it yeah
gu
yeah yeah I see what you mean so it's
so yeah yeah you're kind of on right
track so I'll tell you because it's not
it's not obvious how to do this actually
um so what they did is again this is
just the let's just assume that we've
trained that diffusion model so it
generates given some random noise it
generates a CT image that is in the in
the right distribution of CT images that
we know the image uh lives
in so yeah again to once we train that
model we can just sample it just in the
process exactly as I described and this
is the kind of code that does it you
just generate a random image and then
you solve this nor OD in Reverse where
you have this trained score Network
function that we've
pre-trained so what this paper suggested
is is uh doing a very simple extra step
inside of that uh OD
solver and it says as we solve this uh
OD solver three times as we slowly turn
this noisy image into the into the final
image at each time step that we're doing
that we add this extra update to the to
the image uh on top of the the update
that St that removes the noise from the
image so this is a it's called a
proximal optimization step that's a very
kind of fancy
phrase uh and there's a whole theory of
like proximal optimation optimization
Theory which I'm not going to get into
but what you can think of at the highest
level is this optimization step is just
trying to nudge the image closer to the
solution of the inverse problem and what
it does is it just says okay given the
current image at time step T I want to
update the image so that it's so that
the loss of the inverse problem so if I
do a forward simulation that image to
produce an expected cogram I should try
and minimize the difference between that
expected cogram and the observational
data that I have so it will it will you
could also think of this as a loose
level taking like a gradient step in the
direction of the of the loss function of
the inverse
problem uh so it tries to push the the
the image so that it's so that it's
satis the observation of data and then
and then carries on diffusing reverse
diffusing the image to eventually end up
with a with an image that satisfies the
inverse problem uh at the same
time okay so that's that's probably
fairly complex but the do you get the
high level kind of
idea
yeah
yes we
to
find yes yes exactly yeah so what we're
doing is we're like inter leaving a kind
of gradient descent algorithm to update
the image just like we talked about
before we were doing gradient descent on
the image to update it to match the
sonogram but at the same time we're also
adding diffus we're assuming our initial
image is a gum and at the same time
we're like adding diffusion reverse
diffusion into that image to like help
it give it a prior basically it's
guiding the image to like the image
distribution that we know of so it's
really a really cool method like inter
leaves kind of standard optimization
with with a diffusion models as the
prior
so so
yeah evaluation time what do you mean uh
would have
uh so you you yeah so when you do a new
scan you will always generate a new
sonogram so you always have this label
in the you know this observe data that
you're trying to match to when when
you're updating the the
image
yeah so it's actually really cool
because this doesn't depend on the
observational setup of the scan you just
uh you
just you just compute the gradient no
matter what the observation is set up is
you can still get a graded in that so
it's kind of independent to
that so I mean here's some plots from
from that paper it's just comparing this
uh kind of optimization inter Le with
the fusion model U method uh with some
other kind of state-of-the-art methods
like using Gans to as your prior for
your images and and more traditional
total variation method as well and yeah
at least on the data sets that they show
in the paper this is seems to be a very
itive algorithm for for learning these
these CT image reconstruction
problems okay so I need to stop there so
ndes use nor networks to represent
learnable parts of the equation
discretized ND solvers can be thought of
as nor network architectures uh with
interpretable Dynamics and it provides
this really fascinating link and many
state-of-the-art models like diff Fusion
modeled co rnns uh can be interpreted as
ndes and it's really interesting to
study them so
thank you very much I'll see you on
Wednesday next week uh yeah see you then